et avant de se quitter retour en france
avec cette mobilisation de la fonction
publique à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats les fonctionnaires sont
invités à cesser le travail pour les
salaires l'emploi et les missions
publiques une mobilisation à l'échelle
nationale les syndicats réclament le
renforcement du statut général des
fonctionnaires à des moyens budgétaires
supplémentaires ou encore l'arrêt des
suppressions d'emplois à paris les
fonctionnaires sont bien décidés à se
faire entendre
les précisions avec mika léger ils
étaient plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants réunis ici sur la place
edouard herriot dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris nous sommes à
côté de l'assemblée nationale ils
étaient réunis à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats de la fonction publique la cgt
la fédération autonome la fsu ou encore
solidaire cet appel a été lancé en mars
pour une journée nationale pour les
salaires l'emploi et les missions
publiques ils demandent l'abrogation de
la loi de transformation de la fonction
publique qu'ils accusent de remettre en
question le statut général des agents
publics je vous propose d'écouter
plusieurs organisateurs que nous avons
pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation on considère que dans le
débat public aujourd'hui on n'entend pas
parler suffisamment des salaires des
fonctionnaires du statut on dit beaucoup
et on se paye de mots que les agents
publics sont en première ligne qu'ils
sont formidables on les applaudit même
parfois mais en termes de
revalorisations dame concret très peu de
choses sont faites on n'attire pas de
réunion de rendez vous salarial à la
fonction publique alors qu'on devrait en
avoir une le point d'indicé continue à
être gelée et puis il ya une gestion de
la fonction publique qui continue à être
extrêmement autoritaire un statut de la
fonction publique qui continue à être
détruits on avait l'impression qu'il
fallait tient un certain nombre de
leçons de la crise sanitaire du coc vide
par exemple qu'il fallait plus de moyens
pour les services publics et en fait
c'est tout le contraire
c'est tout le contraire qui arrive quoi
que en fait ils ont tiré aucune leçon de
cette crise sanitaire que dans les
hôpitaux c'est toujours la merde et nous
dans l'éducation ben en fait on gère le
bordel depuis un an et rien n'a été fait
aucune protection des personnels on n'a
pas de masque fournis par notre
employeur on n'est pas vacciner les
élèves sont pas testés des enseignants
sont pas testés en fait on a
l'impression que depuis un an rien s'est
passé et que par contre la pénurie
budgétaire elle a continué
autre cible de ces manifestants les
budgets 2022 qui s'annonce marqué par
l'austérité et les suppressions
d'emplois c'est pourquoi ils demandent
le renforcement du statut de
fonctionnaire l'augmentation des budgets
le dégel des salaires et l'arrêt des
suppressions de postes d'autres choix
sont nécessaires ils sont possibles
c'est ce que nous avons pu lire sont à
des appels à manifester
et c'est ce que ces manifestants ont
essayé de faire au cours de cette
journée de mobilisation